Now the next part of this process that we're going to be building out is by adding our skylight.
Now the skylight, you can think about this as kind of the the general ambient light that would be reflected off of the sky itself.
So if you think about the earth, naturally we have an atmosphere which does reflect light back.
But of course, it's a massive, massive dome.
That's essentially what we're recreating here with our skylight.
Now the difference is we are going to be specifying our lighting again with this whole idea that we are wanting to control our lighting and the effects 100%.
We're going to do that through using a very specific cube map.
Now in this section here, there's something that's not quite accurate to what I said before, but that is an intentional thing here that we're actually going to talk about.
So we're going to go ahead and set up these settings in our project.
So if I jump back to our scene now, in this case, I can go to lit mode because we're actually going to start adding this light so we can see what's happening.
I'm going to go up to my place actors, clear my search, and I'm going to look for sky.
What I'm looking for is the skylight component.
So if we drag this into our scene, we won't really see a whole lot happening right now.
And that's totally fine.
All right. So the settings that we want to change, the first thing is we want to switch the mobility of our skylight to movable.
Now, in this case, the position of my skylight doesn't matter.
It's fine. We could reset it if we want to maybe pull it up above the vehicle so we can see it.
So I'm going to change my mobility to movable.
And then the next thing that I want to do is change my source type.
Instead of SLS captured scene, I want to change this to SLS specified cube map.
Now, from this cube map, we could select our drop down and see all the various ones that are available.
The one that we are looking for is this small hanger, 01, 4K.
So if we add this to our scene, now I'm going to go ahead and bump up our intensity to that 30 so we can start seeing some effects.
I may take it up to 120 just so we can see what's happening.
In fact, let's go ahead and bump this up to 600.
And you can see now we're getting that ambient light reflected in our scene.
Now, just to cover a brief point that I mentioned before about this, not necessarily being the accurate way that you want to do this,
but for the purposes of this class, this is important.
So if you remember that what we're building towards is a neutralized scene, a neutralized baseline.
And one of the sins, if you will, that I've done with using this particular cube map is you'll notice when I open up the cube map and look at the actual texture itself,
it has a lot of more or less like creamy kind of skin tones within it.
This is ideally not what we want to use, right?
We would want to use an HDRI that is for lack of better terms as desaturated as possible.
So I could use this HDRI, maybe go desaturated, do some post settings inside of the engine.
In fact, I will move this off screen real quick and just show you if I go down to saturation and change this to zero.
And I click save.
We should get an update.
We'll go ahead and actually just disable this, re-enable it.
And you'll see how quickly our scene changes.
So again, this is an important note to keep in mind that if you're going to be using an HDRI,
try to use the most desaturated as possible for your scene to, again, to keep that neutralized baseline.
So I'll go ahead and keep this as is and we'll close it and we'll continue to use this skylight.
All right.
The next thing that we're actually going to change here is our cube map resolution.
And obviously we've adjusted the intensity scale.
So what we're going to do is with the cube map resolution, this is going to be visible.
In fact, let's go up to the vehicle here.
Some kind of move up a little bit and we can see within the reflections here, the the sky map itself.
So the actual cube map being reflected off of this.
So right now, the default resolution is 128.
But if I change this to something like, say, for example, 512, you'll see we start to get a lot crisper reflections in here.
In fact, you could bump this up to 1024, although at this point we're kind of introducing more of a placebo effect.
512 is fine.
You'll see some other things that are happening.
But be careful with this.
You don't want to adjust this too high.
So above 8K or 16K, that gets very expensive and might cause some instability.
So with your cube map resolution, we just want to bump that up to get a higher value.
And then finally, you saw that we have our intensity scale.
I have it set at 600 right now, but we will adjust this down as we start having more lights into our scene and we start to see the effects of those lights.
But again, keep in mind that this is just our general ambient light within our scene.
So keep this as is now and adjust this a little bit later.
And finally, one of the other settings that I want to change is this lower hemisphere is solid color.
So by default, in fact, if we expand out our advanced underneath our light, you'll see that we have this lower hemisphere color and lower hemisphere is a solid color.
This is the default behavior.
But because we're using this cube map.
So if we imagine just a invisible line that goes halfway through the engine by default is going to basically discard the information that is the lower half of this HDRI.
And we can re enable that by simply just unchecking lowest hemisphere is solid color and that will get the additional information from our cube map to project basically into our world.
So we'll go ahead and uncheck that lower hemisphere is solid color.